well thank you for being here everybody
welcome to the show hope your weekend
was well-spent
we start today with the big news of the
week end the terribly sad news of course
of NBA legend Kobe Bryant dying at the
age of 41 alongside a to the eight other
people which we shouldn't forget to
include including his teenage daughter
Gianna in a helicopter crash on Sunday
they were as I understand it on their
way to a travel basketball game he was
bringing his daughter to her game and
the helicopter crashed according to
investigators today the latest is that
they're saying it was probably
weather-related there was dense fog in
the area at the time of the crash so I
want to discuss a few things related to
this story and and the first thing I
want to talk about is why a death like
this a celebrity death affects people
the way that it does why does it get
under our skin the way does it does
why are we so shocked by it and my point
is not to criticize or complain about
our tendency to care so much about
celebrity deaths I've seen some of that
online and any time you know a famous
person dies unexpectedly there are
always people saying oh you know he was
just a person like us and why cry about
this if you're not crying about the
thousands of other people who died
across the world you know on any given
day I think those sorts of comments deny
something fundamental about human nature
it's normal that we care about it and at
one level it doesn't require explanation
or justification these are people who if
they're famous people whether they're
you know famous actors or athletes or
what-have-you
they are people who even if we didn't
know them personally they were still a
part of our lives in some sense not a
central part of course but they were a
part and when they die we do feel like
we've lost something and we have so I'm
not looking to justify or explain
but I do think it's it's good to
understand I want to try to understand
why the death of somebody like Kobe
Bryant tends to hit people hard aside
from the obvious which is the obvious
things like he was a young man he had a
family his daughter was killed too those
things are obviously making it all the
more tragic but I want to go deeper than
that I think there's a deeper level of
why we react the way we do to these
sorts of things and I want to talk about
that and then also related to this story
unfortunately we have to discuss the
media's embarrassing performance in
reporting it but as we discuss that I am
going to do something I've probably
never done before it may never do again
and that is defend an MSNBC anchor who's
come under fire for something that
happened while she was reporting about
Kobe Bryant I'm gonna defend her and
there are others who I'm not gonna
defend because they're indefensible so
we're gonna get to all of that but first
before we do a word from expressvpn
listen there are tons of VPN providers
out there you've probably heard of a
couple of them and some of you maybe
have used a VPN before but I only
recommend brands to my listeners that I
believe that if I don't like the product
if I don't believe what the company's
marketing team is saying to sell the
product then I'm not gonna endorse it
and by the way I've turned potential
sponsors away before because well I
didn't believe in their product but I
can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is my favorite VPN on the
market here's why expressvpn doesn't log
your data lots of really cheap or free
VPNs make money by selling your data to
ad companies you don't want that that's
the last thing you want expressvpn
develop a technology called trusted
server that makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your info
second and this frees probably most
important thing especially for what I do
for a living is speed many slow your
connection down or they make your device
sluggish with expressvpn my internet
speeds are blazing fast and unlike other
VPNs you don't have to import or program
anything to use Express VPN you just
fire up the app click one button to
connect and it's as simple as that so
it's it's it's quick it's fast your data
secure and
it's not just me saying this TechRadar
the verge CNET many other tech experts
rate expressvpn the number one VPN in
the world so to protect yourself with
the VPN that I use entrust use my link
expressvpn dot-com slash walsh today
that's expressvpn comm slash walsh and
you get an extra three months free on a
one-year package visit expressvpn
dot-com slash walsh to learn more okay
so here's my thought as we get back to
Kobe Bryant because I've been thinking
about this why do we tend to react so
strongly to celebrity deaths especially
when the celebrity in question is young
and healthy and you know not known for
reckless behavior not a celebrity who in
the back of your mind you're kind of
expecting might die of an overdose or
something like that and not a celebrity
who's been around for 60 years and is
getting older and you know the ones in
those categories where you're sort of
expecting this news about them so when
you go online and you see their name
trending you immediately think oh well
yeah I guess I guess it finally happened
with I think Kobe Bryant a lot of people
had the same experience I did I learned
about it on social media I saw his name
trending on Twitter and I thought oh I
don't know did he say something
controversial or whatever then you click
on it and it's the last thing you expect
to see is that he's dead and that's what
makes the reaction all the stronger and
a big part of the sadness is simply as I
said that he was a young man a father
his child died with him which makes it
just ghastly or even gas clearer than it
already would have been anyway so that's
part of it but I think there's something
deeper which is this we spend so much of
our lives
you know hiding from the fact that we
are mortal beings and then something
like this happens unexpectedly and
forces us to acknowledge this reality a
reality a terrible reality that death is
always with us always walking alongside
us and at any moment it can point its
finger at you and say now's your time
and it will happen it absolutely will
happen to you to me to all of us no
matter what it's as simple as that now
we know this of course you know we all
know it nobody is surprised to learn
that human beings are mortal mortal I'm
not saying that we're surprised in that
sense but in a way we are surprised to
learn it I guess because we spend so
much time repressing that knowledge and
keeping those thoughts at bay and then
when the reality of death hits us in the
face for vermin unexpected direction
it's almost as if we have to relearn the
fact that human beings are mortal I
remember talking to my wife about this
yesterday when I got home and she said
oh did you hear about Kobe Bryant and I
said yeah and then I said oh it's crazy
crazy that was the first first word I
said but really it's not crazy at all is
it someone dying well that's about the
least crazy thing they can do it's the
most normal thing in the world actually
it's the one thing that everybody does
and all of us will do so what's crazy
about it sad or unwelcome yeah crazy no
it only seems crazy because again we
keep death thoughts at bay by lying to
ourselves and telling ourselves that
death is something that can be
controlled if not avoided altogether we
can at least control it we can hold it
off at a distance because it's not our
time whatever that means
if we're young and we have plans and we
have stuff to do we think no I can't die
now I've got I got all I got all these
plans I got stuff on the calendar see
but death doesn't care about that
doesn't care about our plan
or our age or anything really again none
of this is a revelation none of this is
news to anyone but it is a stark reality
that we don't dwell on most of us we try
not to think about it and then somebody
dies somebody who in our minds very much
belong in the category of living someone
like a still young sports legend they
die and we're forced to peer over at the
Reaper in the room the dude with the
cloak and the scythe and go oh yeah oh
yeah and it could also be disturbing I
think to watch somebody kind of go from
present to past to watch someone who is
turn abruptly into was especially again
when in our minds it's too early for
that whatever that means
especially when there's no gradual
transition from is to was somebody dies
from a disease over time and there's
sort of this transition where you're
getting ready for it but in a case like
this it's just the person is and then
they and then they become a was 10
seconds later out of nowhere and it's
disturbing because we know that the same
thing will happen to us one day we will
be a past event you know a memory and
then not even that there was a book
written decades ago by a guy named
Ernest Becker which I just read recently
as a matter of fact somebody recommended
it to me and the book is called denial
of death he was a psychoanalyst and
there's a lot in his theory that I don't
agree with and there's a lot in
psychoanalysis that I find to be pseudo
scientific not you know silliness really
but the central thesis of his book in my
opinion is compelling and persuasive and
it relates to what I'm saying now he
argued that our repressed anxiety about
death is a driving factor in our lives
and in a culture and so much of human
culture in fact according to him is set
up specifically to distract us from and
to evade thoughts of death so
of human culture really at the end of
the day is about managing terror it's
about managing our terror of death even
if it is a repressed or suppressed
terror I think there's a lot of truth to
that and by the way interesting fact
about Ernest Becker he won the poll
surprise for that book a few months
after it was released but he wasn't
around to receive the award because he
died shortly after finishing the book so
a morbid illustration of his point I
suppose
okay well all of that is thoroughly
depressing but I was thinking about it
and and I wanted to share it so there's
that more discuss on this in just a
moment but first a word from LifeLock
you know we all spend a lot of time
online and we put our information out
there all kinds of information about us
the scary thing is that this leaves us
vulnerable right to identity theft which
is why in this day and age if you don't
have some kind of protection against
identity theft it's recklessness it's
crazy not to have protection and that's
why you need life lock every two seconds
there's a victim of identity theft which
means a criminal could be spending your
money applying for loans in your name
even damaging the credit that you've
worked hard to build up over time
and checking bank statements and
monitoring your credit yourself isn't
going to be enough because you could
still miss threats to your identity good
thing there's life lock identity theft
protection life lock uses propriety
proprietary technology to detect and
alert you to a wide range of potential
identity threat threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
stuff that you would never be able to
find on your own unless you peruse the
dark web if you even know how to do that
which I don't in if you if you do have
an issue involving identity identity
identity theft one of life locks
identity restoration specialists will
work to fix it of course no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
with life lock you get identity theft
protection to help protect your devices
against cyber threats for up to 25
percent off your first year just go to
life lock calm slash Walsh that's life
lock calm slash Walsh for twenty five
percent off again that's life lock calm
slash Walsh ok well the other inevitable
thing about
celebrity deaths is that people
especially people in the media will try
to capitalize on the tragedy by posting
hot takes as soon as the death occurs
because they're trying to get attention
and there was a lot of that happening
yesterday and I don't want to highlight
most of it because they're doing it for
attention and if I give them attention
I'm doing exactly what they want so I
don't want to do that
but there is one especially notable
example I think a Washington Post
reporter felicia
san m'as posted an article about kobe
bryant's rape case she posted this
article now it's not an article she
wrote it was daily The Daily Beast wrote
it years ago but what what made this so
callous and you know calling it tacky
would be way underselling it she posted
this article literally hours after he
had died in a fiery wreck alongside his
teenage daughter I mean just um really
didn't wait very long at all I didn't
even wait for the bodies to be pulled
from the wreckage and she's posting this
article and she posted there was no
tweet before this one expressing
condolences or even reporting on the on
the on the story instead the very first
thing she says about it the very first
reaction that she offers is calling
attention to his rape case 15 years ago
and there was a lot of that actually
like I said I'm not going to
specifically call attention to most of
it but a lot of prominent people
especially prominent women on Twitter
immediately tweeting about Kobe's rape
case some actually calling him a rapist
despite the fact that he was never
convicted of anything by the way
now Felicia has been suspended by the
Washington Post
not for the rape tweet but for a follow
up tweets where she posted screenshots
of angry emails she had gotten with the
full names of the people and so that was
a violation of company policy and she
was suspended for that but she offered
no apology in her follow-up tweets and
she made herself the victim she said oh
geez look at all these mean things
people are saying about me as if she
wasn't expecting that right as if that
wasn't the entire point was to garner
this negative attention for herself you
the death of a person of nine people as
a way to do it so that's all you know
III don't even want to get into it
because it's it's this is the point it's
like not what we should be talking about
right now but all these people posting
about Kobe Bryant's rape case I do think
it's relevant to note as I said that not
only is this not the time but by the way
he was never convicted of anything so
you're putting this out there right
after he dies he's not around to defend
himself and but you know who cares we're
gonna it's there's there's no slander a
dead man this is just what we do now but
as I said I do want to also defend at
least one person in the media lots of
people on social media have been
whipping up outrage against an MSNBC
anchor who according to them said the
n-word on-air while discussing Kobe
Bryant maybe you've heard this but
here's that moment where she supposedly
used the n-word on MSNBC listen to this
yeah it seems like he was just the kind
of athlete the kind of star that was
perfectly cast on the Los Angeles Lakers
Los Angeles Lakers kavita if I could ask
you to stay with us so a lot of people
shared that saying oh my gosh she said
the n-word she's racist so on and so
forth
the anchor though came out and and
clarified that she didn't say the n-word
she was actually about to say Knicks but
then stumbles and changes it to Lakers
midstream
so she almost said no it's Los Angeles
Knicks and changed it and then it came
out as knickers so you can hear the K
sound the NIC
you can hear that K sound in the clip
there was no G sound and that
explanation makes sense okay it's a
stumble sometimes people mess up sports
teams and names and things and so it's a
verbal stumble it happens it happens to
all of us we all do it and if you spend
a lot of time on TV you're gonna do it
on TV sometimes now to say Los Angeles
Los Angeles n-words wouldn't even make
sense I mean even if she's a secret
racist and she says the n-word all the
time in her private life which I doubt
the case but my point is even if it were
it wouldn't make any sense of her to say
Los Angeles in words certainly to do it
on purpose I mean is that the theory
here that she's some kind of racist and
she thought that now would be a time to
throw the n-word out there and ruin her
career her life in the process really or
maybe maybe she it was a slip of the
tongue like a Freudian slip revealing
her racism well but again even as a slip
of the tongue it doesn't it makes sense
as a stumble a stutter it's just your
jumbling upwards but as a slip of the
tongue where she accidentally said a
racial slur that she had in her head but
didn't want to say out loud it doesn't
even make any sense that that theory
makes no sense that's not how the mind
works yet this is what people do it
doesn't matter if it doesn't make sense
what we do now is we look for the most
negative possible interpretation of
everything we are constantly searching
for reasons to destroy anyone and
everyone for anything and so we extend
no grace no understanding at all none
okay we dig for the absolute worst
possible interpretation doesn't matter
if it's plausible
doesn't matter if it's likely but if
it's a possible interpretation we're
because yeah it is it is it's possible
that she really said the n-word because
she's a racist and it just slipped out
it's not plausible that it's not very
plausible it's not likely it doesn't
make a lot of sense but yeah it's
possible so what people do is they say
well it's possible so let's just go with
that it's possible and it's negative and
it would destroy her I don't know her
I've got nothing against her personally
but let's just go with it because they
just going for the worst interpreting
the worst spin trying to paint people in
the worst light all the time and
it's I mean it's evil honestly it's an
evil thing
we act like evil people when we do that
now maybe you could say what I'm saying
here is a little bit self-serving
because people do this kind of thing to
me and I get frustrated and maybe there
is an element of that I admit this is
something people do to me where I'll say
something and you know maybe I was
I didn't word it exactly right and it
was a little bit clumsy maybe if you
take this part out of context you can
kind of make it seem like something else
and people do that to me and yeah it's
frustrating because my point is always
do you do you really think that's what I
meant to say is it do you really think
that I meant to say that no you don't
it's just you can make it seem like I
maybe meant to say that and so even if
you don't believe it you're going with
it but anybody who speaks in public to
any kind of audience in any forum will
have to deal with this now where people
are casually sort of ripped to shreds
casually smeared and slandered on the
flimsiest pretense and why for fun I
guess mostly now I've heard some
conservatives who said well she works
for MSNBC and they do this kind of thing
to people all the time so she deserves
it really she deserves to be dishonestly
smeared and potentially have her career
ruined because you don't like the media
company she works for hey how would you
react to that if somebody use the same
logic with Fox News
what if somebody who hates Fox News
smeared somebody on Fox News dishonestly
and said well it doesn't matter if it's
true or not they work for Fox they
deserve it I mean do you hear yourself
and don't you hate MSNBC
precisely because of their propensity to
be dishonest yet now you're advocating
for dishonesty yourself so you
apparently have no problem with
dishonesty so why so then what's your
problem with MSNBC is this really well
they started it they started it yeah me
I don't like being dishonest and
smearing people but they did it first so
what am I gonna do have principles what
am I gonna do have integrity what am I
gonna be a good person but now I can't
be that now I'm a piece of garbage just
like them but I'm a different kind of
piece of garbage so you know I honestly
I hate this so much
and especially when people try to
justify it on ideological grounds they
try to justify it as I'm a fungus
fighting you don't have you know you
don't have the guts you don't have the
stomach to fight like I'm fighting we
got to fight them you're not fighting
it's not for you retweet you you know
you accusing someone of something that
you know isn't true online that's not
you fight with you look you're a warrior
now so you're just a small pathetic
little liar and I don't know you you
think you
some kind of victory by becoming that I
don't think so
it's it's just it's all a bunch of
nihilistic Machiavellian ends justify
the means nonsense and I wish we would
we would stop
especially when look if you're looking
to criticize MSNBC there are so many
valid avenues of criticism you could
turn out of MSNBC any time and find
completely legitimate honest righteous
reasons to criticize you don't need to
latch on to something like this alright
let's move on and over unfortunately to
politics backing up well let's let's
back up a moment there's been a
controversy more controversy this time
because Joe Rogan endorsed Bernie
Sanders and didn't really into I mean it
wasn't like an official endorsement he
said Rogan said on his podcast few days
ago that he's probably gonna vote for
Bernie Sanders and I I think he was
talking about in the primary first of
all but you want to call that an
endorsement and then Sanders campaign
ran with it and acted like it was a
full-throated endorsement why is this
controversial well in is it that Rogen's
conservative listeners are up in arms
are they upset about it no not from what
I've seen I'm a conservative and I'm a
Rogan fan and I don't care that he's
gonna vote for Bernie Sanders makes the
difference to me he's got his own
opinion we don't line up exactly
politically I already knew that I don't
care makes no difference the controversy
is from the left from progressives who
say that Rogan excuse me is a bigot and
a bad guy and thus now bernie is tainted
by the bigotry burning is now a bigot
due to his proximity to this other
alleged bigot now why is Rogan a bigot
well apparently he's told a bunch of
mean jokes he is a comedian and if you
go through his whole catalog of jokes
like speaking of taking things out of
context and being dishonest and trying
to smear people well now we're doing
with Joe Rogan he's a comedian he's got
hours and hundreds of hours of material
out there
Podcast and his stand-up career and so
now they're digging through all of that
trying to find isolated incidents out of
context him saying a bad word or saying
a bad thing that's part of it and then
but I think the bigger part and the
reason why they're doing this in the
first place where they're digging
through and looking for out of context
bits to use against him
the reason they're doing that is because
he raised their ire a few years ago
Rogan did when he came out against men
men competing in women's sports so rogue
especially in the MMA
so Rogan took the radical position that
men are men and thus should compete
against other men in Nadia's women and
this is inexcusable according to the
left it's this is transphobia
it's bigotry it's wicked it's evil so on
and so forth well other candidates are
looking to capitalize and that's why
Biden came out over the weekend with a
brief statement and he said quote
transgender equality is the civil rights
issue of our time there is no room for
compromise when it comes to basic human
rights the civil rights issue of our
time really now
first of all obviously from my
perspective and if you're not a radical
left winger from your perspective this
is already crazy the idea that trans
equality is a civil rights issue of our
time I would say the civil rights issue
of our time is abortion but even from a
leftist perspective if you didn't know
any better wouldn't you expect them to
say that you know I don't know something
like police brutality or you know mass
incarceration or something like that is
the civil rights issue of our time you'd
expect if you didn't know any better you
would expect them to go with something
racial as being the civil rights issue
of our time and at least in that case
now I don't think that police brutality
is the civil rights issue of our time
but at least in that case there's some
meat on the bones there and you can
there's something really there's a some
kind of argument you could make
reasonably that it's at least an issue
but no they go with trans equality they
say that allowing men to change in the
women's locker room that is the civil
rights issue of our time the number one
most important thing now this only
surprises you if you don't understand
how leftism actually works and the
victim pyramid as I have explained many
times trans people are the uber victims
the ultimate victims and their
victimhood claims trounce all other
claims doesn't matter that most of their
victimhood claims are utterly
superfluous and ridiculous and in fact
what they are asking is that they should
be allowed to victimize other people by
for example cheating women out of gold
medals in their sports and championships
and by taking away their privacy in the
locker like what they really want is to
is to be the victimizers of women when
they advocate for those sorts of things
but that doesn't matter because they
this is how it works they they are at
the very top and so all of their
victimhood claims are not only correct
and right and unquestionable but also
are are the most important victimhood
claims that
anybody makes so Biden understands all
this and he is dutifully playing along
with it but I would like to ask Biden
the question if I had a chance or really
if we had a real news media this is a
question they would ask especially at a
debate and it's a very relevant
pertinent question and and that is
simply this
Joe Biden when did you decide all of
this so you've decided that trans trans
equality is a civil rights issue of our
time you've decided you and so thus you
must have also decided that men can be
women if you haven't decided that that
it doesn't make any sense at all to say
that this is a civil rights issue of our
time so you've decided that a dude with
the penis and X Y chromosomes can be a
woman and that he has a god-given right
to go into women's locker room and if
you don't allow him to it becomes a
civil rights issue of our time when when
did you decide that because you're what
almost 80 years old so nearly 80 years
on this earth
ever mention this before
before like just five seconds ago
well over the first 70 years of your
life never mentioning any of this not
once
let me go back to any other time go back
to the early 2000s or even the mid
2010's certainly go back to the 90s the
80s the 70s this guy's been in public
life this whole time you think you're
gonna find him saying anything about
transgender equality what if he asked
him back in the early 2000s when he was
at the very young age of you know in it
50 or something or 60 if you had asked
him a person with a penis it could not
be a woman or if you'd asked him can men
get pregnant what do you think he would
have said did he believe this whole time
that actually men can get pregnant
never said anything or probably not so
he had some sort of not just him but
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders all
these people at some point very late in
life he had this transformations
conversion experience where he realized
some health oh you know what actually so
what can you explain it I think it's a
very valid question isn't I just want to
know what happened was there some sort
of scientific breakthrough that I'd
never heard about did you have a vision
that you have a dream was this a road to
Damascus type of moment what was it now
of course I know the answer to that
question what was it is what it was just
that the political winds shifting and
and his base in the Democrat Party going
so far left especially in recent years
that's what happened but he's not gonna
say that so what would he say um it was
it was somewhat easy for guys like Obama
Obama who we forget that we often forget
was elected in 20 and 2008 as a opponent
of same-sex marriage and then in 2012
for the re-election magically he was a
proponent of it and but he when he was
asked to explain that and it was pretty
easy for him to say oh I've evolved on
the issue and I've realized the blah
blah blah it would be a little bit more
difficult and awkward to say that you
evolved on the issue of whether or not
women can have penises but because what
could possibly justify that evolution
and and the thing is the media knows
that that it would be very embarrassing
for Democrats to have to have to have to
try to justify and explain this nonsense
and so they're never asked to and as I
as I as I often say this goes to show
that media bias and fake news and all
that it's usually about what isn't said
the questions that aren't asked the
stories that aren't covered the angles
that are not exploited its it's not it's
usually not about what is being covered
and what is being said sometimes it's
that and it's not usually that they're
making up stories that didn't happen
although sometimes they do that too but
mostly it's just about what they ignore
and this is a great example of that
where they have I think silently
conspired it's a sort of silent
understanding they all have in left-wing
media we are not going to ask these
people this question yeah we'll ask them
very very broad you know give them an
opportunity for platitudes where we just
say how do you feel about this we give
them a chance to talk about the the need
to be accepting of transgender people
but we're not going to dig down into
that even one inch deeper and ask them
something like when and why did you
decide
when and how did you change your mind
yeah we we asked them that about
same-sex marriage and we would still ask
them that now because we know that they
have a relatively non-invasive answer
ready for it but they couldn't possibly
have a non embarrassing answer for this
because it's crazy and and so we're just
not gonna ask all right let's see before
we get to emails I did want to mention
the Grammys last night I don't know who
was nominated I don't know who won most
of the awards doesn't matter but there
was one little thing that I want to
highlight just because it shows you the
state of the music industry the great
John Prine won a Lifetime Achievement
Award if you don't know who John Prine
is what are you doing with your life but
do yourself a favor and and and look him
up on iTunes I and I only say I meet
people but when I get to talk about
music with people I often meet people
have never heard of this guy somehow
there's a musical legend okay so look
him up on YouTube or something and do
yourself a favor anyway he won Lifetime
Achievement Award well-deserved and he
is one of our great living artists and
then Bonnie Raitt speaking of great
living artists got up to perform a
rendition of one of primes songs one of
his best songs angel for Montgomery
angel from Montgomery by the way is one
of the best American songs in the last
100 years it's a beautiful sad simple
yet poetic song and here's here's right
singing that song at the Grammys last
night
[Music]
named after my mother my old man is
another child
[Music]
dreams were lightning
thunder was desire this all has long
time ago
okay gorgeous rendition which is what
you would expect from Bonnie Raitt who's
a brilliant singer and has been for a
long time I think she's I looked up
she's like in her 70s now believe it or
not but here's the problem
they gave her seventy five seconds less
they ever less than seventy five seconds
to sing that song it's like a
four-minute song everybody would benefit
from hearing the whole song beautiful
song they give her seventy five seconds
and then they uh sure off the stage and
probably partly because they had to free
up six minutes for ariana grande
she of donut licking Fame to perform in
her underwear and here's what that
looked like
[Music]
I need a son
they say which one I said happiness
[Applause]
you string it up by the crazy stuff
so there you go I just want to highlight
that because what a startling contrast
you see on one hand you have soulful
meaningful real authentic music and then
on the other hand you have an idiot
rolling around in her underwear but you
know of course the idiot gets all the
time she gets she gets six whole minutes
to go on with her with her pretty pretty
average I'm not gonna claim that she's a
bad singer okay
she's obviously she's better than me
ariana grande but she's not she's that
great there's not nothing nothing
spectacular about her voice her
musically the lyrics that she's singing
of course are lyrics that anyone with a
sub 75 IQ could come up with even though
you know she didn't even write her own
songs
there's nothing impressive happening
here you know not not great the
arrangements are just typical cookie
cutter pop arrangements so rather bland
singing terrible lyrics standard cookie
cutter melody and arrangement the
dancing even the Dancing's you know not
even that impressive of dancing at least
with Beyonce I mean Beyonce not that
great of a singer her songs are pretty
stupid she is a really good dancer at
least then you've got someone like
ariana grande somebody's pop stars
they're not even really great at
anything yet of course we give her all
the attention I get it I mean she's the
she's the big-name star and people these
days a lot of them have never even heard
of John Prine or Bonnie right but but
that's you know just a sad statement
alright let's let's go to emails but
first if you're a regular listener of
this show you've heard me talk many
times about the pro-life issue I was
just saying it's a civil rights issue of
our time and I do believe that and it's
very easy to come to that conclusion
when you consider the 60 million human
beings that have died from abortion but
we know that as you know we do
everything we can the pro-life movement
to call attention to this issue and to
fight back the laughte is going further
and further off the cliff there was the
New York State law
abortion up to birth the Illinois State
law allowing partial birth abortions so
they are going further and further
deeper and deeper into just this extreme
advocacy for not only abortion but
infanticide think about what Ralph
Northam said about delivering the
children and then making a decision
about what to do with them
ie maybe we kill them so as that's
happening of course the left is also
viciously attacking anyone who stands
for the pro-life cause and we've
experienced that here at the Daily wire
with them coming after our our
advertisers and our sponsors especially
after Ben Shapiro spoke at the March for
Life last year but it's not just us that
are being targeted live action is one of
the best pro-life groups out there they
have been for a long time and one of the
leaders of the pro-life movement and
they're being targeted for censorship in
many different platforms there are
platforms on social media where they're
not allowed to advertise anymore they
were kicked off Pinterest entirely
simply for speaking the truth about
about abortion and this is why you know
our daily wire.com members are so
important your membership help keeps
keeps our cameras on and our microphones
turned up even when the left is
pressuring our sponsors but you can also
be a big help not just to us but to live
action as well and that's why from now
until January 31st a portion of any
daily wired.com membership will be
donated to live action with the promo
code live action to support awareness
and education around the world on this
issue so join daily wire.com and make
your pro life voice heard all right
we'll do a few meet few emails here matt
walsh show at gmail.com matt while show
at gmail.com this is from Corey says
mister Walsh I'm an admirer of
personality assessments as a tool to
better know oneself one's own
motivations and for interpreting the
actions of other people significant to
you I'm a proponent of the ena Graham
test over myers-briggs but both can be
useful for people if you end up curious
I'm fairly positive you are an anagram
one parentheses the reformer and you're
an ISTJ I'm grateful for the show okay
this is something I talked briefly about
personality test last week on the show
and I said I don't believe in him and
ever since then I've been getting tons
of emails from people not only defending
personality tests but telling me what my
personality is according to personality
test because I guess they've taken it
for me but I want to just show because
this is just a great example so Cory
says that you know he believes in the
personality tests and he says that I'm
an Nia Graham one and he gave me a link
which describes my personality and I
want to show you let me show you this is
why it's so bogus okay and so here I am
at the meaning inia Graham Institute
describing what apparently is my
personality and here's what it says the
reformer type-1 the rational idealistic
type principled purposeful self
controlled perfectionist type one in
brief ones are conscientious and ethical
with a strong sense of right and wrong
they are teachers Crusaders advocates
for change always striving to improve
things but afraid of making a mistake
well-organized orderly fastidious they
try to maintain high standards but can
slip into being critical and
perfectionist they typically have
problems with resentment and impatience
at their best they are wise discerning
realistic and noble they can be morally
heroic okay no idealistic and rational
you got the best of both worlds now does
this describe me well of course I am a
hero I mean obviously this describes me
I have I I totally see myself in this
maybe this stuff about being organized I
can't quite claim that for myself even
right now in this very room well you can
see my bookshop look at my bookshelf
does that was like the bookshelf of an
organized person but this is my point I
mean it's obviously I I would love to
see myself in this it's nothing but a
but a glowing
positive review of my personality and
then the only negatives it throws in
there are the kinds of negatives you
would say in a job interview if you're
asked what are your weaknesses and so
you know the negative is I'm a little
too critical and perfectionist
and I can be impatient like okay I mean
I'm fine with admitting that about
myself and it's true actually but here's
the problem this applies to almost
everybody okay almost everyone is
impatient almost everyone can tend to be
critical almost everybody is a
perfectionist in some areas of life and
then the rest of it is just a bunch of
compliments that yes I I am I would love
to believe that I yes I would love for
them so this see this isn't so much
describing me it's more like this is
what I wish I was but I don't know if I
actually am and and I'm sure if I looked
at every you know type twos and type
threes and fours and fives it would be
very similar like mostly a bunch of
really good stuff stuff that I I would
love it if it described me with like a
few token negatives thrown in there but
that's why people believe in personality
tests because they see it they're
flattered by it and they see themselves
quote unquote because it's exactly what
they want to believe about them so now
if a personality test had any hope of
being really valid there would have to
be personality types that are pretty
much a hundred percent negative like
there would have to be some personality
tests that are the reverse of this where
there are a few minor positives but most
of it is really negative there would
have to be personality tests where the
result comes back and says you're a
boring uninteresting person you have no
original ideas you're a follower you're
weak you're a coward
and you know nobody likes you it because
there are people like that in the world
who knows maybe you're looking at one of
them I mean but I would never think that
about myself I couldn't possibly think
that you could never see yourself that
way
we've all met people who seemed to have
almost no redeeming personality traits
at all we've all met just miserable
there should be a personality type that
says you are a miserable a-hole and the
discussion that's what you are because
those people exist yet they don't exist
on personality tests because nobody
wants to be that if a miserable eight if
a miserable a-hole took a personality
test and it came back and came back as a
miserable ayoh because they are
miserable a-holes they would never they
would just they would conclude that oh
this thing is broken hey that's that
thing doesn't work That's not me no show
me a personality type this is what I
want are there any personality tests
where it could come back with a bunch of
positive glowing things like this but
it's also possible that there are
personality types that you could be
diagnosed with that are really negative
show me that personality test maybe it's
there's there's a possibility that it's
sort of valid because you just cannot
convince me I'm sorry I've met people we
all have
not true that everybody has a basically
positive personality that's not I wish
it were true but it's not
finally from Justin says I'm a big fan
of the podcast appreciate everything you
do I'm a 22 year old Christian have been
all my life you've been a 22 year old
Christian all your life huh
so defying your defying the hide I guess
I just got through a saying you know
everybody we're all mortal and time
catches up with all of us but you've
been 22 year old twenty-two years old
your whole life anyway sorry I'm an
a-hole remember that's my personality
time hopefully you can give some insight
into this question which is which which
is older Christianity parentheses
Judaism or Hinduism throughout school
all my history all my history classes
seem to teach that Hinduism is the
oldest religion this seems to be the
consensus online as well the age of the
religion is typically based on the
earliest known evidence of his existence
both religions claim to be the oldest
since both have creation stories as a
Christian I believe that Christianity is
older but I was wondering how you would
answer this question and what evidence
you would point to for your answer
well Justin Justin Christianity is
definitely not even in the running for
the oldest religion in the world
I get that you're incorporating Judaism
and you're saying that's what makes
Christianity the oldest but I don't
think you can do that I mean there's no
question the religion of Christianity
began with the resurrection and
ascension of Jesus in the age 33 or
there abouts that's Christianity's
beginning date and Christianity is is
unique or nearly unique among world
religions in that it has an almost
precise beginning date most religions
don't some do but most don't which is
what makes it hard to say exactly how
old how old Judaism is or Hinduism but
if you go with archaeological and
textual evidence the most generous
estimate you could probably come up with
for Judaism at least with with the with
the Jewish text the Jewish Bible the
oldest
texts in the Jewish Bible the Old
Testament I think the most generous
estimate and what most you know sort of
evangelical biblical scholars will say
probably is that they were written in
around 1500 BC that's probably as far as
you could push it most sort of secular
scholars will say was more like maybe
600 BC that was written but okay even
let's put it at 1500 the problem is that
Hinduism does have evidence of its
existence both in its texts and in you
know you look at monuments and
sculptures and so on there is evidence
of his existence going back thousand
years before that so that's just where
that's where the evidence points but if
your history textbooks are saying that
that Hinduism is the oldest religion
period then your textbooks are still
wrong so you're you you you're your
suspicions that there might be some
incorrect information here I think are
well-founded because that is definitely
not the case Hinduism is definitely not
the oldest religion now if the question
is oldest currently still practiced
religion then maybe you can make a case
for Hinduism those or Austrian ISM which
is a an ancient Persian religion is
probably even older but if it's oldest
religion period then you can go back to
like the fertility cults before the
Neolithic era you know thirty forty
thousand years ago they were even later
or earlier than that they've got
evidence of religious practices so those
would probably the oldest religions the
oldest religions still around today
maybe make an argument for Hinduism
Zoroastrianism still is practiced by
some people I think which is probably
older but no I don't think it's Judaism
which yeah I don't see that as a problem
the oldest doesn't mean the truest
because of the oldest is the truest then
we should all be fertility cultists
right we should all still be practicing
the primitive religions that they
practice before the Agricultural
before the advent of agricultural
societies and I don't think anyone
thinks that so oldest just doesn't you
know mean I don't think oldest
translates to most credible or closest
to the truth or whatever this is just
this is just a question of archaeology
and what the evidence tells us and yeah
I don't think the evidence points to
Judaism being the oldest religion not
even close to it honestly all right good
good question though thanks for the
question and I wrapped that up with of
course the disclaimer that I'm not a
historian or an archaeologist myself so
take what I'm saying with a grain of
salt this is just based on my own
reading but thanks for that we will
leave it there thank somebody for
watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me andrew clip
[Music]